today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescent
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china save virus lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
convalescent
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't be
afraid of it you're going to beat it we
have the best medical equipment don't
be afraid of it felt great like better
than i have in a long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life be
afraid of it all right guys i got to cut
in because before the biden event we do
have a
live republican press briefing listen to
this insanity from secretary of state i
voted against tony blanken but i also
spent an hour and a half in my office
talking with tony
i look forward to working with him as
secretary of state and i'm hopeful
i voted against him in a number look at
this guy because they had executed a
pivot
someone told me gwen stefani is older
than ted cruz is that is that true can
you imagine
there's a difference between that and a
nominee who
is woefully unqualified and i would note
none of becerra's defenders have come
back with anything and said no no
he does know something about healthcare
he knows something about medicine knows
something about science
you know the democrats as a talking
point like to say
they care about science and yet in the
middle of a global pandemic they want
some
strong hype training human services
agency who has
zero scientific background that's that's
unacceptable on the merits
and and it shows i think the wrong
priorities
senator marshall yeah why is this a good
faith no vote
if you're going to vote no on basically
all of the nominees anyway
well i think i'll probably end up about
50 50 but the general theme here is
unqualified
and extreme the people of kansas sent me
to here to do a job
and i'm doing that job the very best of
my ability using my very best judgment
to make sure that we have the people in
place to help get us through this crisis
to help to get our economy going again
figuring out how do we get shot this is
republicans justifying obstruction in
getting kids back to school
those are my immediate goals thank you
here's lankford out of his mind has the
white house
made him available to meet with you if
that's something you're interested in
i have we had the hearings with him he's
had two back-to-back hearings but i've
not personally met with him have met him
before and had
the opportunity to be able to interact
with him either less cause i have one
more and this is just more general for
hhs
we know right now that um there are
illegal immigrants who are either in
border detention facilities or wherever
they are
that are receiving covet testing and
coveted vaccines is that something you
would be concerned about
increasing with becerra heading hhs
yes i'm very concerned about people
being tested for the virus we're testing
code vaccines and
he's been pretty outspoken that visero
wants to also have health care
for everyone who's not legally present
here in the country obviously it's an
enormous shift for us an enormous policy
change that congress has not addressed
in the past
but he's been pretty outspoken that that
is a desire that he wants look at ted
cruz
it is an area that i personally
challenge other nominees on like dhs
to say hey i have a concern that we have
restrictions on people flying in from
central america
in their tests but now you're allowing
people to just physically cross the
border
that have a different standard on that
that's a concern that's a dhs concern
hhs obviously handles the children once
they leave the facility and they go into
their care
people asking about the south dakota ag
yes we covered that on the bonus show
today come in
they've gone back to the locations that
democrats in the past said were kids in
cages
there were actually facilities built by
the obama administration that were okay
for the obama administration to use
obama we're not okay for the trump
administration to use the biden
administration's back to using them
again
so it's just this bizarre thing and
they're basically saying well we have to
keep kids separating look at cruz
they're putting them in the exact same
location that they criticize the trump
administration for doing
that's hhs that oversees the care of
those children once they leave there
and actually i would like to see ted
cruz just slowly slink down until he's
out of camera shot and then go out
i took the liberty to go to the border
with the group of doctors in congress i
guess two years ago
and this is a problem before covet even
we have a limited number of resources
and
and before there was cova there was
tuberculosis and hepatitis
other types of contagious disease which
are more prominent uh
in in mexico and central america as well
so it was a stress before
and then it just becomes a volume issue
trying to keep up with
with all the numbers of people our our
folks down there our doctors our nurses
are very committed doing the best they
can
but but there's a certain amount of
volume that we're able to do and then
this increased numbers is going to
stress them even more and then now we
throw covet on top of that as well
just adding to the the situation here i
absolutely believe we can get to herd
immunity by april or may
we we now know that the vaccinations are
75 80 percent effective after one shot
we've got we've already distributed 95
million vaccinations
i think we'll make it to that hundred
and hundred days pretty easily maybe
even next week as well
and we have the potential to do three
million vaccinations a day
can easily get to herd immunity if our
president's team and our governors do
their job
thank you thank you thank you so very
much
a very very brief press briefing from
republicans
supposedly was going to be mitch
mcconnell as well the senate
minority leader but i guess he's
not here um we will keep an eye on that
as we stand by for joe biden and there
are you you've missed nothing the main
event here is this biden 50 millionth
vaccine event and we're going to have
more news about
upcoming distribution we are very close
sometime in the next
i would say 48 to 96 hours we will have
a third vaccine approved the johnson and
johnson vaccine
it's a one-dose vaccine um
and that is just a really really great
thing the latest numbers from the
standpoint of vaccination
are that we are averaging over the last
week
1.45 million injections per day
that is lower than where we were as you
can see the dark the bars are daily
injections the line is the seven day
average the seven day average peaked
about a week ago nine days at 1.7 then
because of the
terrible weather in different parts of
the country numbers have been down and
hopefully this will go back up but
very well on track for one uh one
million a day for a hundred days
and uh soon soon soon soon i think we
will probably be averaging
two to 2.2 million a day and that's a
really good thing now i do want to
address one
super chat that came in dark just sent
me a super chat saying
here is some money to say vaccines are
good david yeah
so this relates to i confronted an
anti-vaxxer
yesterday uh oh thanks to tyt for the
raid welcome everybody coming over from
the young turks great to have you guys
we're standing by for a big
uh vaccination event um i dealt with an
anti-vaxxer yesterday
and i published my entire correspondence
with her to facebo
to facebook youtube and our podcast
and one of the allegations she made is
that she was shocked i would accept
money to promote the vaccine and it's
like who would pay me to promote who am
i
uh you're trying to vaccinate you know
billions of people
how is it even worth it how is it even a
strategy to pay me
uh i just actually understand the
science of these vaccines that's it
um juicy bacon says david have you heard
about the joy trying to lock in usps new
fleet is gas-powered
shady dude will he be removed yes today
i interviewed ro
khanna and we also have a report on
today's podcast about
how joe biden will remove dejoy because
the postmaster general is not
a cabinet level position biden can't
just get rid of him
so what joe biden is doing is he's going
to pack the postal service
board of governors he's going to add
three left-leaning
governors to that board of governors
that will give
democrats the majority on the postal
service board and then they are going to
say
bye bye to uh louis de joy and we will
have
can you imagine having a postmaster
general
who wants the post office to do well
think about that rather than one that's
trying to uh
to ruin the post office which is a long
tactic from the playbook of
uh of republicans if there's an agency
you don't like
you attack it and say it's terrible then
you're put in charge of it
and you actually make it terrible and
then you say look i told you guys
it's terrible because you made it
terrible then democrats come in and say
here's a plan to fix it
and then republicans say that's too
expensive we can't afford that that's
just too expensive
uh okay so we've got that um i've been
asked about
the south dakota attorney general thing
i am fine talking about that a little
bit we talked about that on the
broadcast
on the bonus show today um
oh you know what let me just deal with
one other thing i keep
seeing this stuff people asking me why
why does dave rubin's youtube channel do
so much better than mine
and i couldn't understand why people
were asking me this so i actually
decided to look into the data
there's many days on which we get 10
times more views than dave rubin's
youtube channel
now there's many right wing youtube
channels that get more views than me
like i don't
if that's the data that's the data but i
just pulled this up take a look at this
yes it's true dave rubin in blue
has more subscribers than i do
but look at views we're in red it's
it's just not even close it's i don't
know where
i don't know why people are getting off
on this idea
of the dave rubin youtube channel is so
much bigger
uh 850 million views to 340 million and
if you look at the day
by day this is this is day by day okay
going all the way back to look this is
october of 2019. hold on a second
if you go all the way back to october of
2019
you can count on two hands the number of
days on which
dave rubin's channel got more views than
we did like i guess there's a day here
around september of 2020
um there's a day here around october of
20.
we are crushing crushing crushing and in
fact look at this
1.1 million daily views
to 217 000 daily views
again if dave rubin was crushing us on
youtube i'd be the first to tell you
he's crushing us there's many right-wing
channels that crush us
but our channel is like 5 to 10 x
from the standpoint of views it's
shocking what is going on so anyway
no more dave rubin stuff we're not gonna
talk about dave rubin anymore just
massive dumps of views coming in left
and right
okay um big thank you
to crazy hawaiian in pennsylvania for 11
months subscribed on twitch
as well as nds and a bunch of other
people
i do want to say thanks to all seven of
you who have just subscribed
via twitch also thank you to
adam prall who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and ellen wallace adam and ellen thank
you so much for your support
uh and yes using the coupon code working
perfectly at joinpakman.com very much
appreciate it
josh says did i get a laptop yet i
should reach out to andrew elias with
exotic pc he's the guy to know
loving the live feeds i have not made a
laptop decision yet
maybe i should speak to this andrew
elias
dennis says what are your thoughts on
canada's slow vaccine rollout and
inability to get any from the us
i honestly don't know anything about it
i don't i just i don't know enough about
it to really be able to uh
comment in any serious manner
so i would i wouldn't i wouldn't be able
to say okay
a few other things to look at this is
really this is what we call weaponized
ignorance
senator john thune from north
south dakota south dakota he tweeted
about his opposition to a 15 minimum
wage
okay and he says i started working by
bussing tables at the star family
restaurant for a dollar an hour
and slowly moved up to cook the big
leagues for a kid
like me to earn six dollars an hour
businesses in small
towns survive on narrow margins
mandating a fifteen dollar minimum wage
would put many of them out of business i
don't know anything about a dollar an
hour that sounds under the table to me
but let's look at what he's saying here
six bucks an hour
and he says he was a kid let's assume he
was 18 years old
when he was making six dollars an hour
okay
six dollars an hour he was born in
nineteen sixty one sixty one plus
eighteen one would know carry nine five
six percent
oh okay that's 1979.
you like my math there 1979
six dollars an hour that's 21.62 in
today's dollars
okay he is saying we shouldn't have a
fifteen dollar minimum wage
when i was a kid i made six dollars an
hour
in 1971 which is almost 22 dollars in
today's money
now does he not understand the time
value of money
or does he understand it but he thinks
his followers are so stupid that they
don't so he uses this what do people
think
he doesn't care okay that may be yeah
that's that's probably it
so anyway that's the latest from john
thune
a very very stupid argument against the
15 minimum wage now i am the first to
acknowledge and i'm going to go into
this in detail on today's podcast
if you look at a state like alabama
which has no state minimum
wage so the federal of 725 is the
prevailing minimum wage in alabama
and alabama is one of the lowest cost of
living states in the country it's really
cheap to live in alabama
i can sympathize with the concern that
for small
service oriented businesses where labor
is the primary input
more than doubling the minimum wage is
potentially a concern
i i'm willing to concede that okay
i'm not talking about mcdonald's where
the vast majority of their costs are
uh rent and food supplies and equipment
stuff like that but i'm saying you know
if you have a small service-based
business where you're you're it's really
labor that's what it is
and you go from 725 to 15 and it's a
really cheap state to live in
we should look at a situation like
alabama in many parts of the country
15 isn't high enough uh so anyway the
point is there's a there's a
respectable fact-based empirical
discussion to have
around the minimum wage which just about
everywhere should be at least 15.
um but the one about i made six bucks an
hour in 1979
is a very very stupid one uh nicholas
bart says david have you covered the
andrew cuomo situation at all seems like
his phone calls to new york officials
are intimidating and trump-like
i have a 15-minute segment talking about
all
four aspects of the andrew cuomo scandal
on today's podcast
it'll be published in about an hour we
go into
uh miscategorizing nursing home deaths
as hospital deaths
i go into sending coveted patients back
to nursing homes
i go into allegations of bullying and i
go into allegations of sexual harassment
now
i know that there's many people who may
be new to my content who
are going to insist and insist david
your hiding that story because you're a
democrat and you never criticize
democrats first of all i'm not a
democrat i've never been a democrat
number two
no no that's not what we do on this
program
i have no i don't deify politicians
i don't care if it's bernie or tulsi
or yang or qu these are just people
they we cr we evaluate what they do we
evaluate what they say
i don't care about party we're going
into all four aspects
some are more concerning than others
everything should be investigated okay
that's on today's
um podcast and we'll have a youtube clip
a little bit later
dom says hey pacman i heard through the
grapevine that you got the squeaker
gavel
i promised a 50 super chat if you got it
loving the show before you know it you
we will have you in a powdered wig and
judges robes
to adjudicate unbanned requests dom came
through
with the promised 50 super chat we will
have a celebratory
gambling there it is
and i actually don't have any unban
requests today to adjudicate there's no
there's none
if i had them to adjudicate i would
tristan says can you help us understand
the obama use the same facility comment
love to know your thoughts yeah that's
true the facility wasn't built by trump
and to some degree that facility was
also in use uh
during during the obama administration
that's true it doesn't tell us that much
about policy
um and i actually interviewed ro khanna
today and we talk about the
immigration situation very disturbing
situation
no doubt about it okay i have a new
voicemail character if you guys want me
to do that or we can do south dakota ag
interrogation video you guys tell me
what you want no troy york voicemails
today i'm not even going to do
a vote the troy york voicemails the
audience has turned
more and more against the troy york
voicemails i used to find them more
interesting because
he would sometimes make arguments that
were not like
the same pedantic boring arguments troy
york has gotten so pedantic
it's just a waste of time so i'm not
gonna do any troy york voicemails today
but i do have two voicemails from a guy
i have not yet
uh nicknamed we have no nickname he's
from jersey
and it's pretty weaponized um so i have
that
or we can look at the ag stuff let's do
ag okay
so this is the deal with the the south
dakota attorney general
the south dakota attorney general jason
ravensborg he um
killed someone while driving on the
highway
and he left the scene and initially
his story was i thought i hit a deer
uh i thought i hit a deer essentially
was was what he's
what his original story and this has
started to become
less and less believable partially
because the victim's glasses were
inside jason ravensborg's vehicle
and a whole bunch of other things have
come out we now have video
of part of the i don't know if we would
call it an interrogation or a
questioning with detectives
and this is the moment where he's told
the fact that the glasses were
in your vehicle signals
that his face hit your car um
i don't know if this reaction is genuine
if he's acting i i really have no idea
okay let's take a look at a little bit
of this video here
that was on the visor the other was in
the glove box the glove box yeah did you
have to take things
off yes i had to move stuff around yes
okay
yes did you notice anything in the
on the passenger side while you were
doing that just glass i mean i was
staying away from the glass i guess
i mean i didn't spend a lot of time so
when you're when you're doing that are
you leaning over the council
yes from the driver's door leaning over
yes okay so you can kind of see in the
glove box and
right which is already popped it's
already popped open yes okay
so did you see the glasses right next to
that
i did not okay you showed me the glasses
the first time
they're the first time they're joe's
glasses i wonder if i weren't i'm
wondering about that
so that means his face came through so
it's kind of weird like
okay you were in an accident and glasses
that aren't yours are in the car
and you were sort of wondering whether
maybe the glasses belonged to the victim
i i mean it's like what how i did
i was i thought i hit a deer and then i
you know i
saw these glasses and i guess i wondered
if maybe they belonged to a person like
no they were the deers it was the deer's
glasses
now i don't know if this reaction is
genuine it also may be a genuine
reaction to him realizing he might be
screwed i don't know
i was thinking that his face did not
come through because it would have been
i thought there'd been blood everywhere
and then now you know if i thought about
it
yeah and then you've had time right his
glasses are right there
jason those are jealous
i did not see the glass until you silk
your shoulders
so the only way for them to get there is
through the windshield
so i don't know i mean listen um i have
a hard time believing that he
he thought he hit a deer that it's tough
for me to believe that i do believe that
he may have been under the influence and
some are saying in the 911 call he
actually he sounds like he's under the
influence
i do believe that it may have been a
panic moment of some kind and he acted
or
i i don't know but a lot of this is just
sort of like not
uh not really adding up so so he may be
in some real trouble
trouble and we're going to be following
that could have fallen asleep is another
possibility i believe there was also an
inconsistency where
he he believed he was on the shoulder
but he was in the median
or vice versa like his statement said he
was on the shoulder but he was really in
the median or
the other the other way um i'm not sure
i'm not sure but we're going to continue
following it and it's not looking
particularly good
there's shock there's processing i get
it i get it
um but he has not struck me as being
particularly forthcoming either
so i i don't know you guys sort of know
everything i know at this point in time
uh okay eugene says can we call it the
squabble
instead of the gavel maybe benedict
downing says
i made four helium atoms a nanosecond
during the big bang and look at where i
am now
okay very good well said thank you i
want to say thanks to
blake a stone for gifting a subscription
also thanks to i need six eggs for
subscribing with prime
and try i gamer for subscribing with
prime
that is three additional people putting
us at 12.
this is a great time to renew your prime
subs if you've not used it if you have
amazon prime and you've not used your
twitch prime sub this is a great time to
use it
but even more importantly thanks tegan
marie and fox on as well
even more importantly this is a great
time
to get a membership on my website
joinpakman.com it's it's really a
perfect
membership ferret says what about a set
wage
increase or five dollars or more
massachusetts would be 16 17 cheaper
states
would go to 12 it's at least the start
yeah you could look at a dollar increase
or a percentage increase
that's a possibility that's a
possibility there's a lot of different
ideas
chakaseki says early in the morn quite
near dawn
ravensborg hit a bespectacled fawn
very much uh jack frost-like almost in a
sense
okay all right we've gotten that let's
go to the new let's go to the new
voicemails this is a new voicemail
character
um this is a guy from jersey it's it's
quite weaponized and there is foul
language i want to warn people in case
there are kids in the room
um let's listen to it what i want from
you is
an idea for what the nickname for this
caller should be let's take a listen
stand back and stand by here we go
well here we go again there's bob from
lakeland slider
you know where he does the flood away
now the reason i say he's from jersey is
at some point in the voicemail he says
he's originally from jersey i guess i
get he's calling from florida
where your buddy came down here during
vacation to get away
to get have a vacation you know florida
you know where we could go to the beach
and
we could go to the stores and we'd go to
the gym
and you know a place like that oh by the
way what's going on with your buddy
biden
he's starting a warmonger again uh-huh
i knew this [ __ ] was gonna start that's
why i hate that so i hate democrats
always
they ain't got no money for no they got
medic you can't get medicaid for all
they'll hell no you can't get paid
college loan
you know paid college i'll [ __ ] that oh
but we could start wars we could have
military bases and butt into all these
uh countries as business and
you know all this [ __ ] and that's
why the world's all screwed up
because america keeps battling at other
people's business
oh commenting on domestic and foreign
policy is this guy
what about the kids in the cages crap oh
biden is a spider's plan that's a real
he fight that that's a real issue and
we're covering that
around with the putting the immigrants
in them in them
migrant camps over there again
on the border yeah hold your nose and
vote democrat
[ __ ] we need to get out of this
democrat republican crap
we need to get away from this [ __ ]
electoral college needs to go too so we
can finally elect
some libertarians you know well so i am
i am in favor of getting rid of that we
actually may have some points of
agreement here
somebody actually gives a [ __ ] you know
people want medicare for all great let's
do it people want paid college they
let's do it
you know i'm getting tired of it of
course i'm
you know most of my friends they're all
leaving they're going to mexico and of
course my friends
before the vietnam war during that time
that's interesting i fled to canada to
get away from that [ __ ]
this guy's not as weaponized as as i
thought actually
here's one more from jersey guy i think
in this one he says he's from jersey
wow i forgot all about this one yeah
david this is bob from lakeland florida
originally from new jersey there it is
riverside new jersey
i'm originally actually i live i grew up
there
and it got the [ __ ] out you know why
because the democrats sent all the
factory jobs to china
excuse me foreign countries because at
that time when i
when they did it wasn't china was like
taiwan and you know stuff like that but
anyway
yeah i like to think of that well even
the republicans did it too
there it is okay so he actually comes
around to some logical things
and then and then and then i was hoping
well maybe i mean the thing about
outsourcing is
everybody agreed that we value cheap
stuff from china
more uh than keeping the the
manufacturing domestic and paying more
for everything like our economy is based
on cheap stuff from china and it's good
he's recognizing that it's
yeah he's the manic moderate maybe
that's the right he's he's recognized
that as both democrats and republicans
that agreed to that implicitly yeah get
a job down in line they say
oh no they had to let [ __ ] donald
trump in there and [ __ ] all that up too
raised hell about that my daddy and my
grandfather and me all raised hell they
threw us out
they threw us out of the out of the
thing because we told them to take
donald trump and
shove him up his ass anyway now i had
that grasp but you know
yeah this is the [ __ ] that goes on
thanks to democrats and republicans
oh yeah yeah oh crowder oh crier got
got kicked off of twitter because he
actually went around
and found out that people were
registered to vote
who lived in parking lots in the middle
i actually
i don't dislike this guy i mean he's
saying a lot of crazy things but some
okay things
so far i think the manic moderate is the
best uh nickname
for highways
abandoned lots you know factory
buildings
yeah i was like i like that one that was
good you know
he went around and actually went there
as people go there and actually
take a picture of people who are
registered to vote
who live in the street who live in the
middle of a street
that was the best one lived in the
middle of the street
[Laughter]
yeah buddy this is america boy thank god
my friends
left and went to canada you know and so
a lot of my other friends moved to
mexico and other parts of the you know
north koreans excuse me some of his
friends went to north korea yeah it's
beautiful this time of year
when during apple uh harvesting season
it's just
amazing there korea and vietnam
and and mexico
i'm thinking about going there myself
you know
yeah buddy yeah this is america
yeah this is america this is the america
we live in all thanks to the democratic
republican parties that you support
yeah buddy i mean you know i certainly
don't support the republican party
i will mostly vote for democrats but i'm
not a democrat
i don't i don't i mean that's that's
interesting that's way more interesting
than troy york for sure
absolutely no doubt about it thanks to
francisco rosales who just signed up at
joinpakman.com i do want to warn people
this coupon code is ending at the end of
this month this month is only 28 days
based on the calendar i'm looking at
so if you want to avail yourself of the
better 21 coupon code this is the time
to do it
also thanks to fearless freckles for
subscribing for six months on twitch
paco taco pope poopin snowflake warrior
gifting five subs and just a lot of
really exciting things happening
via twitch which i appreciate uh putting
us at 23 for the day
i did miss a few super chats which i
want to get to
a ferret queen says foghorn
leghorn surprisingly libertarian emma
says this guy is way more entertaining
than troy york
scott says in fairness have you been to
new jersey the best part is leaving
that's aggressive junie mcgrath is which
of these choices had the worst week
cuomo cruiser the lincoln project i
would say ted cruz
i think ted cruz for sure goatee says i
think you meant robert frost not jack
frost
actually when i said jack frost i i
created a
blend of jack london and robert frost
and i said
jack frost uh yeah jack frost is a
professional snowman that's true
okay don't worry new code same discount
for march oh that's aggressive
that's very aggressive my dad grew up in
riverside new jersey used to be referred
to as a river rat so maybe the name
should be river rap bob
i like uh the the manic moderate for
some reason is appealing to me
we can put it to a vote at at some point
in the future
but uh the manic moderate i'm i'm sort
of liking
okay so we did that oh i do have a
tucker i've got a tucker video i was
going to review with you guys
we'll just turn the audio up here this
is tucker carlson's
um rant about a left wing disinformation
campaign from a few days ago a bunch of
people have asked me to
review this let's just take a look at it
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight we take a lot of digs at the
media on this show and we do it for two
reasons
it's fun and they deserve it recently
we've watched with growing amusement as
our media gatekeepers thrash around in a
frenzy of foaming hysteria
over the possibility that someone
somewhere might dare to present
facts or form opinions without their
express written permission
he can't possibly be talking about fox
freelance thinking is what they hate
most it's a threat to their monopoly
they can't say that out loud so instead
they call it disinformation
oh this is similar to when people say
anytime you you know someone comes to
you and they say oh joe biden stole the
election
and the evidence is that there was like
a van with not enough snacks for the
vote count and dominion and then mike
pillow
did this and then you go that's a that's
a completely baseless conspiracy theory
and they go
conspiracy theory is a term used to
discredit us without taking it seriously
similar to what he's doing here
disinformation is a term meant to
silence
misinformation is the real threat says
the guy who thinks his union has the
contract on bringing you the news
it's ridiculous but before you judge
these people take a moment and feel some
compassion consider how they might be
feeling
right about now imagine if you had spent
30 years making a good living as a car
mechanic
and all of a sudden gm invents an engine
that anyone can fix at home with a
screwdriver
you'd be upset that's how cnn feels
about the internet
it's exposing their scam naturally wait
so is tucker for or against right to
repair on the basis of that example
that's a weird example but
that opens up a whole other camera i'm
still trying to process that example
what they're a little irrational about
it
millions of americans clinging to
conspiracy theories
this is all evidence of radicalization
how could you argue against that
and that's not easy to say it's not an
easy word to use
but it's way past time to talk about
this honestly no one should tiptoe
past this predicament disinformation
networks like q
and on are causing people to lose touch
with reality disinformation networks
that doesn't sound like a misleading
social media post has chucker watched
fox news ever it sounds like a terror
cell
and it sounds that way on purpose the
thing about disinformation they're
telling us
is that it's not simply harmful to you
personally it's not like eating a pint
of ben and jerry's or
sneaking a smoke while the kids are at
school no this information
isn't a sin it's a crime well i i don't
know about a crime
but it's certainly a societal problem
this information
hurts everyone it's an offense against
this country
that's true information is an attack on
america and not just on america
but more critically on something called
what the hell is that our norms
our norms are so out of whack that it
has become surprising when good things
happen
even after four years of us talking you
know night after night
about the norms that are being shattered
he is doing
everything to shred every one of these
norms
how is this even controversial tucker
has taken something completely
undeniable and acting like it's some
kind of
concerted effort to lie about it we
can't allow these kind of democratic
norms to be shattered
so we abided by these norms but this
president is just real in this
administration
just blown right through those norms not
since the red scare
have once good men and women been
dragged into this kind of sabotage
of our democracy and social norms that
may be a little hyperbolic and
histrionic okay
our norms shattered shredded
crushed destroyed blown through
why is it always our norms that are the
first to be attacked
maybe because our norms are democracies
first responders they run to the sound
of gunfire
norms are like the young lieutenants in
vietnam walking point through the rice
paddies
exposing themselves to fire guys i'm not
gonna lie
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about like very often
with tucker i know what he's talking
about and i disagree with it
i i don't have any idea what he's
talking about here in order to save the
platoon
it's a dangerous job being in norm and
never more so than now
you thought underwater welding was a
treacherous gig you feared for the guys
who fix antennas on skyscrapers that's
nothing
imagine being a norm in today's america
they don't last long
okay we'll stop it's all pretty amusing
and it's hard to resist our norms our
norms
on the other hand if we're being
completely honest here and we strive to
do older folks
like this i know fox news's audience is
very much older folks like
is this funny to anybody or compelling
to be completely honest we have to admit
there is a kernel of truth in what
they're yelling about
there is disinformation out there and it
does hurt people makes people stupid for
one thing
but it also impairs i think the
causality is actually different
i don't think it's disinformation makes
people stupid i think
it's lack of education lack of critical
thinking skills
that leads to people falling for the
disinformation i i think he has the
causality reversed
their ability to make wise decisions you
can't know what to do next if you don't
know what's really going on
a lot of people in this country are in
that position right now we saw evidence
of it
just this week we read a research paper
called how informed
are americans about race and policing it
was published by the skeptic
research center check it out online if
you have a minute it's a pretty amazing
document
the researchers asked people to estimate
the number of unarmed african americans
who were killed by the police in 2019
here are the results 44 percent of
another ad that i guess we're able to
skip americans who describe themselves
as
liberal believe the total number of
killed was quote
a thousand or more more than a thousand
unarmed african americans gunned down by
cops is that true
well as it happened we have definitive
statistics on this thing hey you know
what's really funny about this
the numbers aren't that different
between groups
like everybody's wrong okay i understand
that
but if you look at like look at the
little red bars which are
people who believe more than 10 000
unarmed black men were killed by police
in 2019.
the very conservative group it looks
like about
three or four percent believe that the
very liberal group it looks like it's
six percent
like these these numbers aren't even so
dramatically different like
yes we know okay people on the left are
more likely to think
that more unarmed black men were killed
people on the right
less likely but the the difference is
not even that
that big uh between a lot of these
groups you look at
this is just ridiculous it's a problem
that people
don't believe the right don't know the
right numbers i'm not denying that
publicly available you could find them
in about a minute the
actual number of unarmed
african-americans killed by the police
in 2019
was 27. so more than a thousand
versus the reality of 27 quite a spread
and it was not an anomaly the rest of
the study found similar results
self-described liberals for example
believe that a strong majority of people
killed by police in 2019 were
african-american yeah and that's
obviously you know when you understand
the demographics of the country
it should it should be you know there's
there's
lack of information on the left as well
and when you understand that the vast
majority of the people in the country
are
are white um it would be it would take
something
really out there for the majority of the
people killed by police not to be white
of course what matters is the rate
the actual percentage was less than half
that closer to 25
these are not small mistakes a lot of
americans are completely and utterly
misinformed and that has
actual consequences yes public policy
can change dramatically in the basis
of things people think they know but
don't actually know and we have seen
that a lot yeah i mean listen
you you look back at uh the 2020
election
and something like 80 percent of
republicans
thought trump won and then look at what
happened you were able to weaponize
enough of them to create a riotous
insurrection so he's right that people's
mistaken beliefs have real world
consequences that's true
entire police departments got de-funded
so it's worth finding out where the
public is getting all this false
information this disinformation mostly
from fox news a lot of it actually as
we'll call it
so we checked we spent all day trying to
locate the famous
q anon oh this is the best listen to
this which in the end we learned is not
even a website
if it's out there we could not find it
how could q anon exist without its own
website guys
just because it's not possible q anon
has no you know q report
qreport.com couldn't exist
then we checked marjorie taylor green's
twitter feed because we have heard she
trafficks in disinformation she heard
that
but nothing there next we called our
many friends in the tight-knit
intel community could vladimir putin be
putting this stuff out there
the proud boys alex jones who is lying
to america in ways that are certain to
make us hate each other
and certain to destroy our core
institutions well none of the above
actually it wasn't marjorie taylor green
it was cable news okay all right i guess
we get the
the idea of it um i don't know that we
need to watch the rest of it but
very really bizarre stuff unable to
apparently unable to think critically in
any way on that program really strange
stuff
uh okay let me get to a few other super
chats
um big thank you to sandra jimenez who
just signed up at
joinedpakman.com sandra thank you
you are a great person and i really
appreciate you signing up there
also thanks on twitch to wonder doggy
for
the twitch sub appreciate that very much
okay i missed a few super chats let me
get caught up on them
mike wants that new caller called yeah
buddy bob
yeah buddy bob would be good that's not
bad
chaka seki says yoseminite sam
that's not bad that's actually not bad
yo semonite sam
it just has nothing to do with the
caller or anything they said maybe we'll
save that we'll pocket that one
chakaseki for a few a future uh caller
am i going to be streaming the trump
cpac speech sunday yes
in fact let's go over the cpac schedule
there is a rumor that
donald trump may be uh announcing
his 2024 candidacy on
sunday at cpac i believe that if all
goes well i am scheduled to get my
second vaccine dose and i could
i could be under the oh my god it's kill
mead i could be under the weather but my
hope and plan
is to stream this the the cpac event
on sunday uh let's take a look at the
schedule
so today a welcome reception
sponsored by fox nation oh my god okay
tomorrow they have a pla a prayer
and then the pledge of allegiance and
then the national anthem okay
florida welcomes cpac open for business
where governor ron
ron desantis will probably rant about
how great it is florida
is ignoring the virus senator mike lee
from utah will
speak about why the left hates the bill
of rights and they love it
that should be funny um then they are
going to have like what is this even
amendment one m.c carly patrick freedom
of speech governor scott walker
freedom of religion james lankford
freedom of press alex berenson alex
berenson is like the coveted truther
who keeps appearing on fox news pam
bondi will speak
and then josh mandel i don't know who
that is they'll have a sec
a segment or a panel on tolerance
reimagined
that sounds like one where you have to
bring in like token black conservatives
i don't know who any of these people are
but my guess is there's probably at
least one token black conservative in
there
then ted cruz will speak on cancel
culture oh my god okay
uh protecting elections why we must
protect elections
how judges and media refuse to look at
the evidence oh sir they're sort of
going in on hold on let's see here
they're sort of gonna they're gonna go
in on how um
judges who were like yeah none of these
lawsuits have any merit
they are part of the problem with why
trump wasn't given the election back
hans von spakovsky from the heritage
foundation will be there
then they go into amendment five freedom
from
confiscation of private property former
nevada attorney general
adam laxalt he threatened to uh sue me
actually that's a story to tell someday
so there will be that
the cost of tuition
a lot of really dumb dumb stuff senator
tom cotton will speak about keeping
america safe
jason chaffetz will talk about
protecting elections
and a cover-up of some kind senator
marsha blackburn fighting for freedom of
speech
it's almost like a parody of itself
the left's assault on free people the mc
is ben
ferguson of the now that's a name i
haven't heard from for a long time i
didn't know that
ben ferguson was still around matt gates
will speak charlie kirk is going to have
a presentation
um big tech is for sale
rick scott will talk about opening
churches
josh hawley will rant don jr will be
introduced by kimberly guilfoyle
that's interesting that's saturday right
see that sounds almost like worth worthy
of streaming if i'm feeling all right
from the vaccine i might cover that
james o'keefe and then dan bongino will
close that out
then they go to breakout sessions
then okay a lot of nonsense
something on anti-semitism the border
okay so this looks like it's kind of
like the the third tier type stuff
okay next day the final day this is
sunday
they'll have a women's breakfast oh i
don't know about that
they'll have a catholic mat they have
jewish prayer server service
and a catholic mass and a purim luncheon
wow
and then another jewish prayer service
shabbat dinner
lot of different things uh
where is the trump stuff oh that's all
friday oh my god that's all friday i
thought we were looking that's insane
so that's just friday wow
okay saturday we're gonna have to go
through this just a little more
generally rick grinnell's going to be
there
matt schlapp playing a major role
uh devin nunes is going to be
interviewed by trent england
this is like it's just it's such boring
lame stuff
just retreads of the same fake issues a
lot of these people i don't even
these people names i don't even notice i
don't even recognize ken buck and daryl
issa okay i know them
uh the right to bear arms lauren
beaubert will be on the right to bear
arms panel
and dana losch who has attacked me
publicly will be there as well
uh some other stuff pete heg seth from
fox and friends
we're not missing the biden thing right
now okay p heads peg seth is going to be
there that'll be exciting
and then governor christie gnome from
south dakota will speak then they do
breakout sessions okay
then we get to the final day which is
sunday which will kick off with a
catholic mass
and a protestant church service they
will screen
the plot against the president movie
with a q a
wow then they're going to do other
things
larry kudlow will speak about denying
people their prosperity
just none of this is even interesting
like in passing
tom fitton will speak that guy's out of
his mind
protecting elections a lot of nonsense
health rationing
check the number and dial again
amendments they will do a cpac straw
poll
and then donald oh oh oh so this is the
area where
young pharaoh was supposed to speak
until young pharaohs comment about
jews being thieves came out and they've
canceled him
and then at 3 40 president donald trump
will be there
so for me the most interesting things
would probably be
the guilt i mean none of it's really
interesting but
kimberly guilfoyle introducing don jr on
friday sounds interesting
and then trump on sunday especially if
he announces that he's running
in 2024 so i'll i'll hope to cover
um those events and then probably
nothing i don't even think the saturday
stuff is is even worthy of looking at
um so that's my thought uh depending
depending on what's going on tomorrow
afternoon
i will try to cover that sean stringer
says what happened to the election
integrity commission
that was put together after trump got
elected yeah it
ended it was not able to find any
evidence
of lack of election integrity and it was
disbanded
that's basically it that's how that's
how it all went down
all right i do have an unban request
to adjudicate uh youtube doesn't have
this but twitch does have a mechanism
where if people get banned they can
ask to be unbanned and then we can
decide together
i do have my gavel and we are coming
together
as a court of twitch unbans this is a
user named
psycho case he participated
today he created his twitch
account 21 days ago
appeared in our channel for the first
time today
and sent the message is this a libtard
stream they then
sent the message uh they spelled the the
f
word about gay people but with an at
sign for the letter a
they were then banned
they have appealed the ban with the
message
is this a libtard stream
this court has considered this one
very very carefully and this individual
is going to be
made a moderator no i'm kidding this is
going to be this is a perma-ban
and we have ruled there it is
and that request is denied that will be
a permanent ban
i mean it's like that's not even what
are we what are we even talking about
i feel like even some of the kids that
watch the stream would be able to
adjudicate that one
that's like it it doesn't even seem like
those people really even want to be
unbanned
right like why even why even they know
they're not getting on band
unbanned when they send that that
message uh
okay very good so we've got that we are
standing by for joe biden
and uh oh there's also i don't know if
people are interested in this
i had some new there's a a new la
nasa live stream
let me see where this is this is
fascinating as many of you know we
covered the nasa
uh perseverance rover landing
on mars some days ago and
i believe that they were having a press
conference
with some really interesting new stuff
see if i can find it here oh people's
cats and dogs seem to like the gavel
that's funny
uh oh no this is not what i thought okay
no no this is actually not that
interesting
where was that nasa live stream hold on
a second
um sadly i'm unable to find it
nasa perseverance
video first ever video perseverance
rover
yeah well let's at least look at the
video that was released it is
fascinating it is
absolutely fascinating stuff
here we go indicate shoot deploy
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed
this is the actual landing acceleration
now for people who don't remember
at a certain point a shoot deploys
and what you're seeing is a camera
looking up from the rover
with the chute up above and the velocity
her current velocity is 450 meters per
second
at an altitude of about 12 kilometers
from the surface of mars
heat shield set press advance has now
slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated this allows
both the radar and the cameras to get
their first look at the surface
current velocity is 145 meters per
second
isn't that something 10 9 and a half
kilometers above the surface
that's mars by the way
yeah it does look like vegas before it
was developed lastly solution
3.3 meters per second altitude 7.4
kilometers now has radar lock on the
ground
current velocity is about 100 meters per
second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute
we are coming up on the initialization
of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines look at that
about 90 meters per second at an
altitude of 4.2 kilometers
ovf salad we have confirmation that the
land of vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
[Music]
we have timing of the landing engines
and with that we have coveted on mars
at about 2.6 kilometers from the surface
mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated
we are currently performing the divert
maneuver current velocity is about 75
meters per second and
they're diverting off the surface of
mars
here in safety bravo we have
completed our terrain relative
navigation current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude of about
300 meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
look at this
we are conducting the sky crane about to
protect the flyclean maneuver
and there it's lowering the rover down
about 20 meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
tango delta touchdown confirmed
perseverance
amazing amazing stuff
really incredible stuff i mean just
unbelievable video unbelievable video
and just imagine what we're going to get
back
uh in the in the in the years to come
just truly truly stunning stuff okay
other super chats daniel says who is in
char who is in to crash the purim
luncheon
if there are bagels and locks count me
in that's not bad
that's maybe maybe the one event i would
go to at cpac is the purim luncheon
particularly if there's brisket matt
says
love the gavel props to your props
and the gavel is used by el chapoli in
colorado yeah
people have told me that a famous uh
mexican comical character
yes i've been uh advised of the
similarity there
i um i i am aware of it let me just
see if i could if i am able to find
that other live feed
rover mission yeah i'm struggling to
find it
did we miss the biden event oh no no
everybody's still waiting for it okay
just making yeah that was weird it
looked like it was over
seems like it's just delayed not like
the biden administration to be late
let's check the calendar and see if
anything did indeed get moved
2 30 p.m eastern time no they are
running 30 minutes late
that is really odd really really odd
everybody's standing by okay well no
problem steven says don't ben shapiro
is going to be at that luncheon if i
went to see i don't know
is ben shapiro even going to cpac does
anybody actually know i've not seen that
it's unclear to me that ben shapiro at
this point is flying to florida
or florida either really
yeah i've not seen his name on there
ben shapiro lives in florida is that
true i thought ben shapiro lived in l.a
strange okay all right well fair enough
okay um let me move on i did have
a couple of other now here's something
interesting
sometimes people ask me why i play the
bad voicemails
instead of the good ones i have to tell
you like
with total peace and love to everybody
that calls in the good voicemails
are really few and far between like
really really
anything that's in a lot of times people
call and like they're not angry
but they just use up the full maximum
three minutes to not really say anything
um let me see here
i have one jimmy from philly voicemail
let's just listen to that just to see
what it is jimmy from philly
wiped so apparently you're
uh
you're a cuckoo boy when it comes to uh
bad information or great information for
you as a progressive
as to trump's defense lawyers
i sent you videos
i'm already lost i already don't know
what he's talking about
on absolute truth on how i uh
dominated one of trump's
defense lawyers william j brennan it's
just just a complete fact
i mean i don't know what he's talking
about
i sent it to your uh email i mean uh
it amazed me you wouldn't cover
something like that
it did what what is he talking about he
owned trump's lawyer
he's a [ __ ] i don't know he's a
philadelphia lawyer i mean he's here
that's a scumbag
what can i tell you yeah i'm from philly
i mean everything there is corrupt
yeah as if i'm checking emails like that
frequently
as i've said before we get 6 000
messages emails tweets and stuff a day i
i'm lucky if i see 0.1 percent of it
walls yeah i mean you know it's like
i guess anywhere else in the united
states if you have money
uh you're gonna do better criminally
that's right a private lawyer better yep
which is why i don't understand half the
arguments with black people i mean if
you're going to
do crime i mean
case in fact mom the attorney that i
still use today
you know all the black people that hire
him
and i meet them in the audience these
criminal hearings uh they [ __ ] love
them i don't know what the hell jimmy's
talking about but
just for kicks okay i'm gonna play
a random quote normal voicemail
you tell me if you think these are
interesting because these are the
alternative these are the alternative to
um like the stuff that that i'm normally
uh playing okay like this is here's just
an example voice i'm picking a random
voicemail i'm not
being i'm not attacking whoever this is
but this is just like a quote normal
voicemail
hello baby this is anna from miami
argentina from miami
um i got my first dose of the modern
vaccine today at my community
health care center and while waiting
with other
patients we started talking
and i can't believe it the clinic is
causing information without other
centers calling
other centers because they have more
have
more vaccines than people
i asked for an appointment this morning
and i got an appointment for today at 4
30 p.m
and they were talking the nurses that
there were
three or four people who had opponent
and didn't show and they would have to
throw away the vaccines
and my daughter is 40 works at the front
desk of a hotel
and i see all her workers
i see the cashiers at the grocery store
so this goes on for three minutes like
is this a is this the type of voicemail
people want
let me know let's take another just
again these are just random examples
random examples
um here's another one okay tell me if
this is interesting
hey david uh i'm a first time caller
into your show
but i have been listening to you for the
last few months i really appreciate a
lot of your opinions
i'd like you to speak about whether or
not you think that
um twitter and facebook should be
regulated as a new public sphere
which i realized would allow more of the
conservative hate speech
such as the stuff that was popping up on
parlor
but i also think that at times
liberal left-leaning extremist
organizations who maybe don't espouse
the same kind of hatred are scooped up
into that and i do think that twitter
and facebook
can start to use that as a tool to
silence all types of speech that goes
against the establishment
um so all non-establishment left-wing
pages
would also be targeted so i was
wondering if you thought that maybe
regulations of
um the public's of those all right so
like is that interesting you know we've
done 10
10 videos about this issue uh so i mean
maybe that's interesting i'm not sure um
let's see um
here's another random one i don't know
actually this might be repeater hold on
hey david what's up man
to do with king pharaoh and bringing him
on
first and foremost they're well aware of
these israelites the guy that you
actually
have done the show with peterson i
believe his name is he's he's been
interviewing these israelites for a long
time
now here's my issue my problem with them
is the divide that they suffer
here right so they fall victim to the
same thing that we all do
the problem is with the with the black
israelites
is that this is an america so we've been
taught this divide from the beginning
so obviously there
oh
so this one just cuts out he calls back
six times on this same issue
like okay i don't know that that's
something that we could really do
um let's see just like i'll do one other
sample
just to see what people think
here's one more hey david this is vigo
from detroit
i just wanted to say i think you're
doing a great job i love your lives
um actually my favorite part of the
lives is just
the the stuff that happens before the
event itself on
well you're part of it now my friend
live and then
uh your recent live you mentioned that
uh this thing about covid and
all the you know anti-vaxxers
anti-masters
you know kova deniers thing uh i would
definitely like you to see
i would like you to see i would like to
see you do
more stuff on that because i know people
who
um are cova deniers but weren't
necessarily trump supporters
okay so anyway as you can see like when
we get a hundred voicemails typically
the ratio is out of a hundred voicemails
one and we love everybody it's great
everybody's calling and we love
everybody's perfect and beautiful you
know all these different things but as
far as like what can i use on the
broadcast show
i need something under 90 seconds that's
got a clear point or question so that
narrows it down from every hundred we
get to probably
four that i can pick from and i use one
of those and then you've got
you know four to four to six from every
hundred that are like whacked out you
know
stuff like the troy york stuff or the
other guy so like that's what we're
dealing with
that's what we're dealing with so when
people ask for good voicemails
the point is we're doing the best we can
we're doing the best we can and and uh
anyway okay i'm mikey says
jimmy from philly's white intro gets me
every time
i still don't know if that's what he's
saying
i don't know if that's what he's saying
he seemed it sounds like he says jimmy
from philly
white but he might be saying something
completely different
i have no idea it's really hard to tell
and i don't even want to go back to it
at this point
okay we are standing by 40 minutes late
now for a joe biden event
related to achieving 50 million
vaccinations in the united states
let's actually look at the exact numbers
and see what we have here
okay the centers for disease control
said on wednesday that's yesterday
about 45 million people have received at
least
one dose including 20.6 million who have
been fully vaccinated
the work to distribute the vaccine comes
as more than 503 thousand have died so
are we not actually at 50 million yet
that's interesting or maybe that
information is lagging a little bit
um yeah i don't know so anyway
joe biden is going to be commemorating
that today we're expecting kamala harris
cpac starts tomorrow my thought is i'll
cover a little bit of cpac tomorrow live
and then the trump speech on sunday
where he may be announcing that he's
running for president
in 2024. that's my thought that's my
plan as of right now
thanks to dagger six as well as the
senate
rahenki trish the dish
emitzkowski and insert clever username
also turtle and wonderdoggy
for signing up via twitch very much
appreciate that
five of those people are ones i didn't
already thank before
so that'll put us at 30 that'll put us
at 30. um
okay buffalo says what about changing
the voicemail time to 90 seconds and
setting guidelines for people to follow
if they want to get their call read on
the air
so it's a google voice number i'm not
aware of any way to change it to only a
90-second voicemail it's a three-minute
limit i'm not aware of any way to uh
change that um lindsay says wait what
happened this week with the lincoln
project i don't even know yeah
when somebody brought that up i have no
idea
i have no clue what that was about can
anybody tell me what did happen with the
lincoln project let me see
uh lincoln project
lincoln project
young men accuse lincoln project
co-founder of harassment but that was
almost a month ago
um the rise and fall of the anti-trump
lincoln project okay maybe that'll tell
us what's going on
i'm as curious as other folks are
which maybe not that curious actually
okay uh
oh my goodness
the lincoln project's members fall from
their perch of anti-trump's fame to
political grifters
sidestepping sexual predation in their
midst has had the velocity of a super
collider
the depth of the crater from the
detonation may not be known for weeks or
months to come as more victims of
co-founder john weaver's sexual advances
come forward and the group's craven cash
grab is unwound
i like this article the group's
questionable spending and tactics were
in plain sight last year even before
the election public disclosures showed
that the lincoln project was not making
strategically minded media buys
but rather was producing provocative ad
content usually targeting trump
that brought cathartic joy to millions
of americans and helped pry donations
from them and in the end the founders
paid themselves millions while probably
creaming
unreported millions more in commissions
from ads and fundraising
but it wasn't just the hinky
self-dealing finances that went ignored
the group's tone and crass language
regularly mirrored trump's own demeaning
rhetoric
founder rick wilson a former guest on
this program called trump supporters tin
toothed rubes and mock them by using a
stereotype southern accent i thought
rick wilson spoke in a southern accent
maybe i'm not remembering that senior
advisor jeff
timmer's constantly profane tweets
included one directed at senator lindsey
graham
with the sentiment to f yourself okay
all right well so i guess it's basically
what we expected oh here we go joe biden
[Music]
this is awkward
is this the 50 millionth vaccine
[Music]
you and i talked earlier about the
medical issues
shoulders
all right
this will be me tomorrow
nothing to it
okay
[Applause]
there it is
[Music]
is this fouchy back here does anyone
know sort of looks like him
doesn't usually wear a lab coat number
one because it's vaccine it's going to
go on your shoulder
side effects you're going to just go
along
body achieve your headaches all wrong
okay when we're done
you're gonna have a vaccine card you're
gonna bring that back for dose number
two
i've got my vaccine card kept in a very
safe place i'll be
laminating it afterwards
we are watching vaccinations apparently
50 million i think that is
how does he decide when to wear a lab
coat i wonder
and by the way why has no one told megan
mccain when she gets to get a vaccine
[Music]
someone just showed up in twitch chat
followed 30 seconds ago
and called me and biden a cuck and he's
already banned my name is elizabeth
i'm gonna be an administrative advisor
really going through these quickly i
like it i mean this is how you could do
it
we need tens of thousands of vaccinators
dust number two is in 21 days i'm going
to give you a vaccine card you're going
to bring that back
okay that doesn't put that and i'm going
to need to see the top of your shoulder
these are some strong vaccinate i kind
of like this i don't know why but i love
it
i think i was going to get one
the bad news is we're only at 49 million
so they're gonna be doing a million of
these on camera it's gonna be a while
i hope you guys are sticking around
i would prefer a better mic setup yeah
this is like a zen thing remember the
moment of zen at the end of the daily
show i don't know if they're still doing
that i haven't watched it in
[Music]
which is due in 21 days okay so this is
the pfizer vaccine 21 days between doses
modernist 28 days and uh expecting
approval by monday of a single dose
johnson johnson vaccine just one dose
[Music]
double mast fauchy liking the technique
i think
[Laughter]
all right well thank you all
dr fauci thanks for your leadership
thanks for being here
two weeks ago uh uh
i uh spent some time with you and dr
francis collins
excuse me uh the director of national
institute of health and nih
he gave me a tour of the vaccine
research center in bethesda maryland
and uh it's the place where our top
scientists spend
years researching and developing
vaccines and treatments of all kinds of
for all kinds of viruses
the brilliant team there made possible
the rapid deployment and development of
covet 19 vaccines and they're truly
remarkable
and this administration will follow the
science to deliver
more breakthroughs you know uh
we are doing that to beat cop coven 19
and other diseases like cancer
which is something that's so personal to
so many families including
me and kamalas and many of yours
we've asked dr eric lander renowned
harvard mit scientist to serve as my
science advisor and head of the office
of science and technology policy and
co-lead
the president's account of the
presidential council on advisory science
and technology
these are the white house offices that
bring together the country's top
scientists
to address our most pressing needs and
they'll be part of the work to develop a
darpa-like advanced research effort on
cancer and other diseases just like we
do
darpa in the defense department which
develops breakthrough
projects to secure our national
security and relatedly i'm delighted to
see
five of the nation's leading cancer
centers
are joining forces today to build on the
work of the cancer moonshot
i was able to do during the obama biden
administration to help break through
silos and barriers
in cancer research we're making progress
there's so
much we can do so much progress
within our reach and that's why i'm
thankful to the folks here today
for getting their vaccine shots gerald
bond who uh
uh who and corey hamilton uh both d.c
firefighters i said to corey that you
know uh
that old expression god made man then he
made a few firefighters
thank god we have them and linda um
linda bussey is the manager of safeway
grocery store in bethesda
victoria lagerwood rivera who is a local
school counselor
and elizabeth callaway who's a
registered nurse who administers these
shots
and the more people get vaccinated the
faster we're going to beat this pandemic
that's why one of my first goals in
office
when i was just before i was sworn in i
indicated that
my goal was to get a hundred million
covert vaccine shots
in people's arms in my first hundred
days as president
looks like it'll happen at first critics
said that gold was too ambitious
no one could do that then they said it
was too small
that the bottom line though is that
america will be the first country
perhaps the only one
to get that done and today i'm here to
report we're halfway there
50 million shots in just 37 days since
i've become president
that's weeks ahead of schedule even with
the
setbacks we faced during the recent
winter storms
which devastated millions of midwestern
midwestern cities
towns and also the same in the south
we're moving in the right direction
though despite the mess we inherited
from the previous administration
which left us with no real plan to
vaccinate all americans
and every time we administer another 50
million
shots i'm going to use that milestone to
report to the american people on our
vaccination program and on our overall
fight against this pandemic
hopefully the next one's in 30 days i'll
tell you
success and the failures and here's the
deal
here's the deal the story of this
vaccination campaign is like the story
of everything hard
and new america does some confusion is
setbacks at the start
and then if we do the right things we
have the right plan to get things moving
that's what we're seeing right now the
weeks before i became president the
previous administration saw six million
shots administered last week
this coming week we will administer over
12 million shots
double the pace in just six weeks that
we've been in office
other milestones we've increased
vaccination distribution to states by
70 percent nearly 60 percent
of people over the age of 75 have now
received at least
one shot it was 14 6 weeks ago
and close to 50 percent of people over
the age of 65 have at least
one shot now it was eight percent
six weeks ago it's important because
people over 65
account for 80 percent of all the cova
desk
additionally about 75 of the people
who live in long-term facilities have
gotten their first shot
and those cases are at the lowest level
since reporting began in may
here's how we've been doing it pull up
an image on that increasing the supply
my team has worked very hard with
vaccine manufacturers
pfizer and moderna to ensure we have
enough supply
for all adult americans by the end of
july
when we had discovered the vaccine
manufacturers weren't being prioritized
when it came to securing supplies they
needed
to make the vaccine we fixed the problem
i use the defense production act to
speed up the supply
chain for key equipment which has
already helped increase vaccine
production
last week i toured the pfizer facility
manufacturing facility
in a plant in kalamazoo michigan it's an
incre it's incredible
the precision the safety the pride
and the sense of purpose everyone
involved in that process and project
has we've all seen the news about
johnson and johnson's vaccine
the idea of a third safe and effective
vaccine is very promising
the food and drug administration the fda
is reviewing the data
and review recommendations from outside
committee of experts
that will be meeting tomorrow now let me
be clear
we are going to do this the right way
the fda will decide on emergency use
authorization
of a vaccine based on science not due to
any political pressure for me or anyone
else
no outside factors what i will say
to the american people is this if if
the fda approves the use of this new
vaccine
we have a plan to roll it out as quickly
as johnson and johnson can make it
we'll use every conceivable way to
expand manufacturing of the vaccine
and we'll make even more rapid progress
on overall vaccines in march
i'll have more to say about this in the
days after the fda review
look we've been laser focused
on the greatest operational challenge
this country has ever undertaken
administering shots in the arms of
hundreds of millions of americans
we're increasing the number of
vaccinators
one we found was you may have the
vaccine but not enough people to put the
vaccinated vaccine in someone's arm like
you just saw
right we brought back retired doctors
and nurses
we've already deployed more than 1 500
medical personnel you see during
national disasters
from the federal emergency the federal
emergency management agency fema
and we commissioned our commission corps
from the department of health and human
services in the defense department
including the national guard
supplying vaccinators we're lining up
thousands
more to do the vaccinations we're also
setting up more places for people to get
vaccinated
as of today we provided 3.8 billion
dollars to states territories and
tribes to create hundreds of new
vaccination
centers and ramp up the existing ones
there already
working with governors across the
country in red and blue states
to bolster their efforts to stand up
hundreds of vaccination centers
from stadiums to community centers
houses of worship
large parking lots we're providing
personnel and equipment
and covering the cost for the states
including for the use of their national
guard which have been they're incredible
today jill and i i should say tomorrow
jill and i will travel
to houston texas to tour one of the
first federal
mass vaccination centers and to thank
everyone involved
this is an example of the kind of
partnership between
federal state local governments and
public and private partners
that's going to get this job done we
also sent millions of
vaccines to thousands of local
pharmacies all across america
to make it easier folks to get the
vaccine shot
like they would their flu shot going to
familiar place familiar
folks that they can trust and know to
get the shot
and for folks who didn't live near don't
live near a vaccination center
or a pharmacy we're deploying mobile
units
these are special vehicles and pop-up
clinics that meet folks where they live
and where they don't have transportation
to get the shots
that i like get to the places to get the
shots that's solid we've also started to
send vaccines directly to community
health centers
to help the hard the hard to reach folks
in cities and small towns in rural
communities in black latino native
american communities
that have higher rates of covent
infections and deaths
than any other groups as a result of
these round-the-clock efforts
in five weeks america's administered the
most shots of any country in the world
any country in the world with among the
highest percentage of population
fully vaccinated that's progress we
promise
it is true that other than israel the
u.s is really the place to be as far as
vaccines go right now we can talk about
why
those are coming down but i need to be
honest with you
cases and hospitalizations could go back
up
with new variants as they emerge so
i want to make something really very
clear this is not a time to relax
we must keep washing our hands stay
socially distanced
and for god's sake for god's sake wear
a mask some of our progress in this
fight is
because so many americans are stepping
up and doing those things
and the worst thing we could do now is
let our guard down
of course it's my hope to come back in
the next
next uh report that we've after we've
done another 50 million
another 50 million shots before the end
of my first 100 days
but here's the critical point as hard as
it is now to believe
we're going to hit a phase in this
effort
maybe as late as april or may
where many predict that instead of long
lines of people waiting to get a shot
we'll face a very different scenario
we'll have the vaccine waiting we'll
have
ramped up vaccine supplies we'll have
administrative
folks to administer the shock people
won't want it to the most of the people
who aren't eager to get the shots
at least that's been the prediction i
don't think i think i don't think it's
going to happen i think more people see
other people getting the shots
it's going to build confidence but you
know at the same time they're people who
live in hard to reach areas
who can't get them and there are folks
who are hesitant to take the shot in the
first place
we all know there's a history in this
country of of
subjecting certain communities to
terrible medical and scientific abuse
but if there is one message that needs
to cut through
it's this the vaccines are safe and
effective
and i believe as you see your neighbor
your husband your wife your son your
daughter getting it
that you will be much more inclined to
get it
listen to dr fauci listen to the
scientists who developed these vaccines
and the extensive and rigorous review
they went through
i did i took my shots publicly to
demonstrate to the american people
that it's safe and effective but the
time is coming
maybe 60 to 90 days when the supply
is adequate but not enough people can
access the shots
or don't want them to address that
challenge
we're going to launch a massive campaign
to educate people about vaccines
that they are safe and effective and
where to go to get those shots in the
first place
and we're going to bring together
leaders of all segments of our society
to educate and encourage
all americans that get vaccinated so i
hope the senate
will soon confirm a key leader of that
effort
my nominee for the secretary of health
and human service
javier barcera who did so well in this
hearing this week
i hope congress passes the american
rescue plan which i've been pushing
which
which provides funds for everything we
need to do to beat this pandemic
time to pass that a long time now
critics say the plan is too big
that it costs too much but let me ask a
rhetorical question
what would you have me cut what would
you have me cut out
on vaccines alone if we don't invest
20 million billion dollars to vaccinate
the nation doesn't that make sense
or 160 billion in total
towards the pandemic for testing to
protective gear
to vaccine production and distribution
i'm ready to hear any ideas on what will
make the american rescue plan better
stronger and effective
but we'll have to answer who will get
helped
and who will get hurt i want to close
with this
the question i ask i'm asked most often
is when will things get back to normal
right my answer is always honest and
straightforward
i can't give you a date i can only
promise that we'll work as hard as we
can
to make that day come as soon as
possible
while things are improving and we're
going from a mess we inherited to moving
in the right direction
out a significant speed this is not a
victory lap
this everything is not fixed we have a
long way to go
and the and that day when everything
gets back to normal
depends on all of us it depends on
congress passing
the american recovery act research plan
recovery plan
and also for us to remain vigilant
to look out for one another i've said it
before
wash your hands stay socially distanced
wear a mask get the vaccine when it's
your turn
when your friend or neighbor or loved
one is eligible encourage them to get
vaccinated
and when all above all remember
we can do this this is the united states
america
there's nothing we can't do when we do
it together
so it's not over yet but we're getting
close
and god willing if we do all we know we
have to do
we're going to beat this beat it sooner
than later
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you for your time mr president mr
president whatever happened to your
promise from
seven weeks ago that if democrats
looks like no questions will be taken
here
no questions for the time being
and off he goes oh wait maybe he's gonna
have a little something else
oh his mask
and there it is
all right vaccinations need to continue
increasing that's the message
and in principle they will um
all else being equal and everything
being possible tomorrow my plan is to
stream around three eastern
where it will be the keynote cpac speech
of day one it'll be don jr introduced by
kimberly guilfoyle that'll be a real
party um
and then we will see you back on sunday
of course for the closing of cpac
the rare weekend stream the donald trump
speech we are going to raid
someone on twitch why don't we raid
man i don't even know there's nobody
let's raid
let's raid the stock guy we've never
raided the stock guy
let's see how that goes appreciate
everybody who join me and hope to see
everybody tomorrow
subscribe on youtube follow on twitter
and then you'll be notified when there
are
future streams nothing better than that
you